okay if we're not careful the United
States is soon going to be at war with
Iran and this is of course the same Iran
that has stuck to every provision of the
Iran nuclear deal until of course Donald
Trump decided to void that deal
unilaterally and I told you earlier this
week the Donald Trump is adding
sanctions to Iran Iran has done what any
rational actor would do in that
situation which is they said well listen
we didn't break the deal we stuck to the
conditions of the deal if you are
unilaterally voiding the deal and you
are adding sanctions to us then we'll go
back to researching and developing
nuclear technology which could be used
for weapons and I think it's important
for me to restate in case there are any
bad faith actors out there waiting to
pounce on me
I don't want Iran to develop nuclear
weapons
I don't want Iran to have nuclear
weapons I have not been a someone who
has claimed ever I would argue that the
Iranian forces of power are good faith
actors I have not said or done or nor do
I want any of those things but this is
obviously the logical decision if you
are in Iran's position as a result of
Donald Trump's decisions and now Donald
Trump is starting to scale up
hostilities and Donald Trump is trying
to end all Iranian oil steel and copper
exports Iran is now heading closer and
closer towards an economic crisis and
now the pre-war propaganda starts and I
don't know what's true and what isn't to
be perfectly honest with you United
States officials are now claiming that
Iran is preparing military strikes
against the United States in the Middle
East they say that the that Iran is
getting ready for attacking commercial
and military ships in the Persian Gulf
could it be true sure absolutely is it
actually true I don't know United States
has a long history of having leaders
that lie to us about so-called imminent
threats to create military engagements
for what they perceive to be political
benefit US intelligence also seems to be
making the assessment that Iran's
actions might be to deliver
goad Trump into taking action since
those actions could be politically
problematic for Donald Trump and for the
United States given our almost constant
disastrous involvement in the region for
decades at this point in time and
there's the risk that that could be bad
for Donald Trump politically although at
the same time it could be good for Trump
politically to get involved in a
conflict with Iran you may have heard
over the weekend that there were four
attacks on oil tankers in the Persian
Gulf they have not as have yet been
blamed on Iran it's under investigation
according to our Secretary of State and
the Trump administration has very
quickly shifted into reviewing military
plans for Iran which are starting to
smell like and starting to look like and
starting to sound like the pre Iraq war
era and the lead-up that eventually got
us think it was about a hundred and
thirty thousand troops in Iraq and in
fact a very similar number a plan being
presented to Donald Trump which would
move a hundred and twenty thousand
American troops to the Middle East if
Iran attacks American soldiers or ramps
up nuclear development or does the other
things that the Trump administration
claims Iran is thinking about doing or
preparing to do we heard from Trump
national security advisor John Bolton
who's right in there with this plan of
going into Iran and he has been in Iran
Warhawk for a long time and in fact he
wanted to go into Iran when he worked
for George W Bush and he was not able to
convince George W Bush to do it we
thought maybe his presence as national
security adviser would give him another
shot and it seems that we're closer than
we have been at any other point during
the trump presidency to John Bolton
getting that opportunity and we're
talking about a serious engagement here
okay 120,000 troops that's not a 1,500
troop peacekeeping or training mission
this is a large-scale operation that has
been presented to trump there are
articles which are using the term
drifting we're drifting towards war with
Iran that's not the right imagery Trump
has been pushing us towards war with
Iran ever since he decided to bail on
the Iran nuke
without Iran having done anything to
deserve that and the hilarious thing is
that now Trump administration officials
have started to pay lip service to
things like you know we would prefer a
diplomatic solution with Iran but we
can't take anything off the table it
would be bad strategy to take military
action off the table we had a diplomatic
solution
it was the Iran nuclear deal which
diplomat Barack Obama put in place and
Donald Trump has unilaterally voided
without good cause and so when the
newspapers cover this including the
Washington Post in The New York Times
who have done very good investigative
work over the last several years the
newspapers covering this need to stop
playing coy with the language drifting
towards war is very passive language in
a way considering what a plan might look
like the United States is the party that
is causing this not the party reacting
to what Iran is doing everything Iran
has done and I am no defender of Iran by
any means I've been hugely critical of
the regime there what Iran is doing is
the obvious reaction to what the Trump
administration has done this is all on
us and specifically on the Trump
administration because of his actions
and the Washington Post in the New York
Times should just say in their op eds
that Trump is pushing us towards war not
that there is this passive sort of
floating in the ocean drift in that
direction no more pussyfooting let's
actually tell it like it is because
that's what's going on and it's really
bad